[Musique]
moi j'étais plus jeune fille énergique
puis aussi une chercheuse de troubles à
l'école je le faisais souvent surtout de
classes chaque fois qu'elle était
ressortie place
[Musique]
ouais c'est con ça bosse et qu'on me
c'est à la sortie des classes h fait
connaissance avec allah et endress de
jeunes migrants venus de loin à la n'a
que cinq ans lorsqu'elle quitte
l'algérie adresse lui est né au
venezuela
il atterrit au canada à l'âge de 10 ans
moi ce qui a été à chaque secteur les
venu il ya eu une grosse tempête de
neige finnois geste venu à mon petit
chandail un choc
là j'ai mis ça je sais comme mon papa
un chérubin noël nous sommes inquiets ou
la veille de noël je savais prester
connu et moi on hadji avait passé ses
deux jeunes de 17 ans ont bien plus que
l'immigration en commun tous les deux
ont une adolescence tumultueuse moins
cher qu'à très colérique mais au début
c'est que je faisais et c'est dans cette
affaire je fais 6 pt bakrie cela en
classe merci mon dieu je commence à
déraper
j'ai commencé à fréquenter les personnes
sont des gamins des rues bébé big three
meuble ni personne qui n'est ce pas une
grosse poubelle à la elle n'a jamais
flirté avec les gangs de rue et son côté
rebelle son allergie à l'autorité la
plonge dans le pétrin j'avais pas encore
six adultes
c'est pas faux j'avais pas comment les
profs vous parlez moins direct je me
fâche et du rex un prof une m'énerver
j'ai redoublé ma surrender 2
quand j'ai redoublé c'est là que j'ai
réalisé faut que j'arrête diniz et c'est
la fièvre du basket qui fait tout
basculer le ballon et leur brevet de
sauvetage pour les jo chez de lorette ya
pas une gêne mais qu'est ce qu'une
passante est qui et combien ai-je pas
rester chez moi je dois jouer au basket
depuis cinq ans il dribble pour les
dragons
j'ai quand même essayé travailler tous
ensemble même si vous boudez même si
vous êtes en colère
le basket n'est pas qu'un simple jeu de
ballon et de tanis nous on veut vraiment
se servir de cette passion-là qu'ont les
jeunes d'uribe qui ont en travers du
basket comme levier d'intervention
sociale qui fait martin dussault
travailleur social pas comme les autres
qui a créé bien dans mes baskets
programme d'intervention sociale unique
au québec
on veut essayer de développer des
habiletés sociales qui vont faire que
les jeunes au travers de leur parcours
d'adolescents vont être capables d'avoir
des outils pour fonctionner finalement
dans la société
maintenant
[Musique]
bien dans mes baskets cinq équipes de
gars 4,9 fille une vingtaine
d'intervenants et de bénévoles certains
joueurs s'entraînent jusqu'à cinq fois
par semaine deux équipes masculines ont
d'ailleurs remporté le tournoi
provincial cette année ça représente
quoi le bastiais pour vous en donne une
classe personnes qui ont dérangé par son
père
pénétrez là haut où tu sens bien c'est
comme notre zone de confort de la maison
qu'on dit exactement la même chose que
moi
au basket nous défendre moi comme je
suis pas motivé à aller à l'école mais
comme coach il ya le basket après ça
s'en vient comment pris la journée
ça m'intéresse c'est comme une drogue
noël c'est une bonne ça va parler du
zouk
sébastien est un coach de basket c'est
d'abord et avant tout travailleur social
il joue un rôle clé dans la vie dallas
et denver sc2 12 parcours
ces deux jeunes là j'ai eu la chance
d'être introduit auprès de très tôt dans
leur parcours ça fait ça fait quand même
quelques années le ça fait cinq ans dans
les deux camps
ils sont passés par toutes sortes de
de hauts et de bas j'avais souvent des
conflits avec ma mère aussi bassin il
parle aussi un numéro supplié ses
patients vraiment aider la famille
l'atmosphère de chez moi
pour ses 20 ans à la maladie et au
basket
ok
s'est assagi elle est devenu plus sage
plus mûr très fier d'elle parce que je
vois que à la malaxer tout à fait une
autre personne
[Musique]
focus sur les appareils pour ton examen
sébastien fait aussi une grande
différence qu'on part en drive
salez
on ne sait pas vraiment comment gérer
une citation au now l'appui vraiment des
messins sebastian qui cette école qu'est
ce que ça fait de savoir si les acteurs
ménages gardes et je trouve ça beau
jusqu'au bout c'est un grand privilège
c'est un grand privilège qui nous laisse
entrer dans leur vie qu'ils nous fassent
confiance
depuis 2011 96% des finissants du
programme bien dans mes baskets au
poursuivi leur cheminement scolaire un
exploit dans une école où le taux de
décrochage frôle les 40%
je tenais colle avec des besoins
particuliers
et je pense que bon on y répond avec
d'une façon particulière on n'est pas la
seule l'école un milieu défavorisé on
n'est pas la seule école que dont les
jeunes ont des besoins particuliers
il faut pas arrêter de de créer
d'innover de penser des façons
différentes de travailler avec avec avec
nos jeunes parce que la société évolue
et puis ben non si vous évoluez
aujourd'hui j'ai de la colère que moi
mais c'est ce que la cij plus mature je
comprends mieux
pigeon
mais calme et mieux que d'acheter son
lot de scènes
moi je manquais de sas mois mais moins
cher
j'aurais jamais cru que je serai amené à
la malle acte aujourd'hui
endress devrait décrocher son diplôme
d'études secondaires d'ici quelques
semaines
il souhaite poursuivre ses études au
cégep
c'est là je vais imprimer puis je
chanterai pas
c'est une équipe aussi jeune mais je pas
le lâcher masquer la défaite de fédérer
accumulés au cours des années 2006 il ça
c'est sûr que je garderai toute ma vie
alors complété une autre année à jeanne
mance et déjà des équipes américaines
lui vendent leur corps et la santé de la
chance d'aller aux états unis depuis les
etats unis sont réputés pour le basket
parce que c'est un rêve pour tout voir
et tout ça
[Musique]